[Música]
el capitolio de eeuu amanece bloqueado
tras el ataque del viernes un policía
murió y otro resultó herido cuando un
hombre en automóvil los embistió en un
intento por romper el cerco de seguridad
el atacante también falleció por un
disparo de los oficiales con una
procesión de patrullas se rindió
homenaje al oficial caído
américa latina' cumplió 100 días desde
el inicio de los planes de vacunación en
la mayoría de los países sin embargo las
regiones están lejos de presentar cifras
óptimas es debido a los retrasos en las
entregas de medicamentos mientras tanto
en argentina el presidente alberto
fernández él dio positivo pese a que ya
fue vacunado
tirán se opone al levantamiento gradual
de sanciones y exige a eeuu que sean
retiradas en un solo paso en el marco de
las nuevas negociaciones indirectas del
tratado de nuclear que iniciaron en
viena del martes
joe biden espera volver al pacto que
abandonó donald trump en 2018
[Música]
una feliz mañana mi nombre es ángela
gómez y aquí comienzan las noticias de
france 24 iniciamos el informativo en
eeuu pasado el mediodía de este viernes
un hombre en un vehículo atropelló a dos
policías del capitolio en washington y
luego arremetió contra ellos con un
cuchillo uno de los agentes el oficial
william evans fue asesinado el
sospechoso identificado como no a green
de 25 años también murió
aunque los congresistas se encuentran en
receso el capitolio fue cerrado y la
policía e hizo un homenaje a su
compañero caído con una caravana de
patrullas informe de rodrigo sedano
de nuevo la guardia nacional protegiendo
el capitolio de eeuu apenas tres meses
después del asalto al capitolio por
parte de seguidores exaltados de donald
trump un asaltante mató a un policía e
hirió a otro frente al congreso el
oficial que murió fue identificado como
william evans un veterano con 18 años de
trabajo en la policía del capitolio
dos agentes de la policía del capitolio
de eeuu fueron trasladados a dos
hospitales diferentes y con el corazón
encogido anunció que uno de los agentes
ha sucumbido a sus heridas el sospechoso
identificado como no a green de 25 años
y proveniente del estado de indiana fue
disparado por los agentes al salir de su
vehículo con un cuchillo en la mano
justo antes lo había embestido contra
una de las barreras de seguridad que
protege al capitolio para muy guango
aproximadamente a la una de esta tarde
un sospechoso entró en lo que llamamos
la barricada norte del capitolio el
sospechoso en vistió con su cuchara dos
de nuestros agentes y luego chocó contra
la barricada norte en este momento salió
del vehículo con un cuchillo a la mano
por el momento la policía no ha
esclarecido las razones por las que
green podría haber cometido el ataque si
bien descartan por lo pronto el móvil
terrorista no parece estar relacionado
con el terrorismo pero obviamente
seguiremos investigando para ver si hay
algún tipo de nexo en esa línea los
congresistas se encuentran actualmente
de vacaciones por semana santa por lo
que el edificio se encontraba
prácticamente vacío el presidente de byd
en quien lamentó el suceso al decir que
tiene el corazón roto tampoco se
encontraba en washington pues había
salido temprano para su residencia de
camp davis terminada la jornada a los
compañeros de evans lo homenajearon con
una procesión de vehículos policiales
que acompañó su féretro hasta el
instituto forense
también en eeuu el presidente yo bain en
revocó las sanciones impuestas por el
gobierno de donald trump a funcionarios
de la corte penal internacional por ser
inapropiadas e ineficaces los
funcionarios investigaban a tropas
estadounidenses oa sus aliados por
crímenes de guerra en afganistán y
palestina y aunque el jefe de la casa
blanca expresó sus discrepancias por las
medidas de ese organismo y dejó claro a
través de su secretario de estado-
anthony blinken que terminó la amenaza e
imposición de sanciones económicas y
restricciones de visado en relación con
la corte
el presidente de argentina alberto
fernández dio positivo para kobe 19 en
una prueba de antígenos y espera
confirmación en una prueba pcr tras
presentar 37 3 grados de temperatura el
mandatario de 62 años que ya fue
vacunado con con el medicamento sputnik
hebe recibió la noticia del día de su
cumpleaños y dijo que ya se aisló
preventivamente aunque seguirá
trabajando en argentina se han aplicado
más de 4,1 millones de vacunas y 682
miles de personas ya están completamente
inmunizadas
para información de todos y todas me
encuentro físicamente bien y aunque
hubiera querido terminar el día de mi
cumpleaños sin esta noticia también me
encuentro bien de ánimo agradezco desde
el alma las muchas muestras de afecto
que hoy me han brindado recordando mi
nacimiento
y américa latina' cumplió este viernes
100 días desde el inicio de la
vacunación en algunos de sus países pese
a ello la situación en la región está
lejos de ser óptima muchas de las
naciones se encuentran en medio de la
tercera ola de la pandemia y sufren
retrasos en el envío de vacunas y sin la
infraestructura suficiente para inocular
más de un año de pandemia pero tan solo
100 días de vacunación en américa
latina' esta cifra redonda se alcanzó en
un momento crítico para la región en
medio de retrasos en la distribución de
vacunas y cuando varios de sus países
están inmersos en plena tercera ola de
la pandemia
el reciente aumento de casos está
desbordando a los hospitales de varios
países por ejemplo las tasas de
ocupación de las ucis superan el 80 por
ciento en todos los estados brasileños
excepto en dos foros del air streets el
país mejor situado en la carrera por la
inmunización es chile que se sitúa entre
los tres primeros del mundo en tasas de
vacunación
la paradoja chilena se aprecia sin
embargo en el alto número de contagios
de las últimas semanas tras la
flexibilización de las restricciones
ayer viernes el país sumó 8.000 nuevos
casos y el pasado jueves se decretó el
cierre de sus fronteras la vacuna se
transforma en una alternativa de salida
a este gran problema pero también se
transforma en la causa de otro problema
es decir esta comunicación
triunfalista respecto de que somos el
país que más rápido vacuna que somos
felicitado internacionalmente mandó una
señal a las personas respecto de un
cierto relajo pero la situación más
crítica de la región la vive sin duda
brasil actualmente es el segundo país
del mundo en número de contagios y
fallecidos por corona virus y muchos de
sus estados se encuentran en estado
crítico con las ucis colapsadas y sin
espacio en los cementerios la vacuna
para muchos es un alivio ciertamente es
un alivio si dios quiere hay una vacuna
para todos lo antes posible porque mis
hijos aún deben vacunarse
colombia por su parte cumplirá apenas
dos meses de vacunación el próximo 17 de
abril criticado por su lento proceso
actualmente ha inoculado a más de 2
millones de personas en reino unido se
identificaron 30 casos de coágulos de
sangre en pacientes que fueron vacunados
con astrazéneca contra kobe 19 la
agencia reguladora de medicamentos se
dijo hoy que no había recibido tales
informes de eventos de coágulos después
del uso de la vacuna de baión tec y
fisher pese a que siguen apareciendo
casos de trombos la autoridad británica
la agencia europea de medicamentos y la
oms se reiteraron que los beneficios de
la vacuna superan cualquier riesgo pero
algunos países se restringen su uso
el gobierno de irán pidió a estados
unidos que levante todas las sanciones y
rechazó cualquier medida paulatina de
las restricciones
washington y teherán aseguraron
previamente que mantendrían
conversaciones indirectas en viena desde
la próxima semana como parte de
negociaciones para reactivar el acuerdo
nuclear de 2015 eeuu dijo que la
atención se centraría en los pasos
nucleares que irán tendría que tomar
para volver al cumplimiento de ese
acuerdo
hablamos con nuestra corresponsal en
iran catalina gómez ángel sobre la
reiterada petición de teherán de no
aceptar el levantamiento gradual
escuchemos iran ha dicho desde un
comienzo que es eeuu el que tiene que
dar el primer paso y levantar las
sanciones económicas impuestas por el
gobierno del expresidente de donald
trump cuando se retiró de este acuerdo
nuclear en el 2018 pedirán también ha
dicho en el pasado que eeuu tendría que
compensar económicamente irán por las
pérdidas económicas ocasionadas por
estas sanciones económicas que ellos
consideran ilegal pero muchos analistas
piensan que hay muchísimos discursos que
tendrán que derrumbarse antes de llegar
a un acuerdo y eeuu volver a este
acuerdo nuclear y levantar las sanciones
y es que washington también ha dicho en
el pasado que se irán el que tiene que
dar el primer paso y volver a cumplir
todo lo acordado en ese pacto nuclear
firmado en el 2015 sin embargo
muchísimos analistas y especialmente
técnicos aseguran que habrá que hacer
acuerdos conjuntos y escalonados para
que ambas partes puedan volver a este
acuerdo y volver a reactivarse ayer el
director de la organización de energía
atómica en irán ali-akbar salehí en la
red social clubhouse estuvo hablando con
algunos periodistas locales y dijo que
él era optimista y que no se negaba a
una negociación coreografiada y
escalonada para volver a reactivar este
acuerdo nuclear y para entender estas
diferentes posiciones dentro de irán hay
que entender la disputa con los más
radicales que se niegan a cualquier
acercamiento con eeuu
hasta aquí el informativo ya volvemos
siga con nosotros
[Música]